[Music]
the following is an excerpt from the
debut pursuit of wonder affiliated book
notes from the end of everything
perhaps to be human is to struggle one's
whole life to find some solid ground to
stand on
and then die never coming anywhere close
and perhaps that's not even a bad thing
to know the true meaning of life and
self is to do what with it
end the mystery and the game what then
perhaps one day we will find some
unifying theory of everything
and perhaps somehow this will make
everything better but what are the odds
that we still care about the point of
life
after we've found it imagine a movie in
which you knew
exactly why and what everything was from
the start
imagine a life if we found a theory of
everything or equation that connected
the mysteries of quantum mechanics
and einstein's theory of general
relativity and we understood the very
core of how and why
the universe worked what difference
would this really make in terms of the
meaning of
life would two different people still
not watch the same movie
and experience and interpret two
different things
we would of course all agree that it's a
movie and on how the movie works
but when it comes to meaning there will
always remain a perceptual layer
completely relative to the individuals
observing it
because of this if we found the
overarching ultimate truth of existence
tomorrow
half the world would not believe it the
other half would fight for it
and as a whole we would be no different
and if somehow the whole world did agree
upon one truth
what then utopia what then
the truth we seek when considering the
quality and meaning of our lives
is not an outward truth not a truth that
resolves the questions of the universe
but a truth that gleans inward and
assembles into a stable self
that can be integrated seamlessly into
our perception of the whole around us
a truth we can't ever truly have truth
is not even the right word here
there is no right word here that's the
point
i sit here writing thinking about my
being about the strange relationship i
have with this life
and this plane of existence i think
about how alive i feel right now
while writing how potent this moment is
how insane and beautiful it is
how important it has been to me in the
past thinking
writing talking and reading about
earnest experiences
and attempts at living personally the
direct confrontation with the challenges
complexities sufferings and plights of
the human condition
have provided me with some of if not all
of the most profound
potent and beautiful moments of my life
and i wonder if i would have ever
experienced any of those undeniably
worthy moments
if life made sense if it didn't hurt and
overwhelm me
how beautiful would the night sky be if
we knew exactly where it went
and how the stars got there how
incredible would a view from a
mountaintop be
if we knew exactly why the rocks and
trees were the way they were
would we ever be inspired to create art
and form interpretations out of this
life
what would i have written about what
would i have read about how would i have
ever found love or
friendship or connection with others why
would i have ever laughed or cried
what would i be doing right now would
there be anything to say
anything to live or die for i don't feel
that my life would have been any better
if i had known any more of what it was
all about
in fact i think it would have only
worsened the whole thing
we seem to so desire certainty an
immortality
a utopic end to conflict suffering and
misunderstanding
and yet in the final elimination of all
darkness exists light with no contrast
and where there is no contrast of light
there is no perception of light at all
what we think we want is rarely what we
do if we ever got what we did
we would no longer have anything what we
really want is to want
to have something to ceaselessly chase
and move towards to feel the motion and
synchronicity with the universe's
unending forward movement
like how all great relationships and
friendships are comprised of two people
who counter balance one another
through various intricate oppositional
forces and traits
so too does the human exist in
relationship with the universe
the relationship between us and the
universe must persist with a
counterbalance
a confrontation a give and take a
rational faced with the absurd
a meaning faced with the meaninglessness
the finite faced with the infinite
like most relationships it has its
rather intense ups and downs
and we have our differences but we stay
in the relationship
because inside us both for some reason
we still want each other
this video was an excerpt from the brand
new debut
pursuit of wonder affiliated book notes
from the
end of everything which i'm very happy
to announce is now available
and can be found through the link in the
description the book is written by me
the writer and creator of pursuit of
wonder
so if you enjoyed this video or enjoy
pursuit of wonder content in general
the book will likely hopefully sit
nicely alongside your interests
in the book we follow the mind of a
fictional narrator who
after being diagnosed with a brain tumor
makes efforts to finally and fully
reconcile with his life
while loosely chronicling the
development of his cancer through a
collection of journal-like essays
posthumously discovered on his computer
we explore the narrator's reflections on
concepts like time
being death anxiety creativity happiness
wonder absurdity and much more if you're
interested
again you can find the book by clicking
the link in the description below
thank you sincerely in advance if you do
choose to purchase it and i hope you
enjoy
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video